[Musica]
la vita mi ha regalato un lavoro che mi
appassiona molto insegno e in questo
rapporto con i ragazzi imparo sempre
qualcosa anche oggi in questi bellissimi
interventi e il signor archeologia una
materia che a voi potrà sembrare chiusa
in un polveroso passato invece che ha
tanti risvolti Anche per capire il
nostro presente perché noi cerchiamo di
ricostruire la storia attraverso le
tracce lasciate dall'uomo e in
particolare i manufatti che lui ci ha
lasciato e questi manufatti parlano di
noi sempre ieri come oggi perché noi
siamo abituati ad ascoltare la voce
delle parole ma anche le cose se ci
pensiamo bene parlano tantissimo del
nostro modo di essere i vestiti che
Indossiamo i libri che abbiamo sul
comodino i cibi che mangiamo Appunto e
sono tutti specchi del nostro status
economico e sociale del nostro livello
culturale del mondo delle nostre idee i
nostri sentimenti i nostri gusti Inoltre
l'archeologia è anche un modo per vivere
tante altre vite curiosare perché grande
curiosità è sempre lo stimolo
fondamentale nello studio nella ricerca
e nella vita che sono uomini che hanno
stratificato la storia e ecco e dal loro
confronto in fondo impariamo un po' a
conoscere meglio anche noi stessi dicevo
i manufatti Però fino a una quarantina
d'anni fa
l'archeologia si occupava solo dei
manufatti belli cioè quelle espressioni
delle Elite culturali che producevano i
mosaici le statue i gioielli le
portavano nei musei li esibivano invece
appunto da una quarantina d'anni si è
abbiamo imparato ad ascoltare molto di
più a guardare molto di più quelle cose
che fanno parte del quotidiano dell'uomo
per dare voce anche a tutti quelli che
noi chiamiamo i popoli senza storie cioè
quelle classi sociali più basse le donne
gli schiavi che appunto non sono mai
narrate dai grandi autori antichi che si
occupano invece della macro storia e fra
questi temi ha preso grande impulso
anche il tema dell'alimentazione perché
anche lo speaker precedente ricordava
quanto anche il cibo sia importante
nella nostra propria vita e quindi
abbiamo di questo vi voglio proprio
parlare di un progetto che si è appena
concluso dove con tanti altri colleghi e
tanti altri enti del territorio abbiamo
cercato di ricostruire appunto il cibo e
il vino consumati Nelle mense dei
veronesi a partire dalla metà delle
palafitte fino al medioevo per cercare
di capire appunto le tradizioni le
continuità e anche le innovazioni che i
cambiamenti
dell'ambiente del clima ma anche della
cultura dei popoli che si sono succeduti
hanno portato è un progetto quindi
complesso perché studiare il cibo e il
vino vuol dire studiare tante cose
insieme da la coltivazione l'allevamento
che portavano sulle tavole appunto i
vegetali e gli animali a tutto quello
che sono le pratiche poi per lavorare le
materie prime gli uomini che facevano
questi lavori agli spazi agli strumenti
che usavano ma anche poi tutte quelle
che sono i processi per la conservazione
per la cucina per la cottura dei cibi ma
anche le informazioni le esportazioni
che portavano sulle tavole degli antichi
anche prodotti ben lontani per esempio i
datteri nel mondo romano e questo
complessità che permette di studiare un
sistema che è alimentare ma
inevitabilmente anche appunto sociale
culturale lo dobbiamo studiare con tanti
sguardi diversificati è stato questo
forse il valore più bello che mi porto a
casa di questo progetto cioè lavorare
insieme uscire dagli steccati dei propri
ambiti disciplinari per collaborare per
incrociare gli sguardi per contaminare
le discipline partendo da quelli che
sono i nostri abituali sistemi di studio
quindi i passi degli autori antichi i
dati che raccogliamo negli scavi ma
dando voce anche a tanti altre reperti
degli Scavi per esempio i semi Carboni
Le ossa degli animali degli uomini che
analizzate con tante fonti diverse e
appunto incrociando le sguardi diversi
hanno dato quello che credo sia il
valore aggiunto di questo progetto
perché oggi la ricerca lo si diceva che
stamattina deve essere multidisciplinare
deve incrociare le persone
Avrei tante cose da dirvi ma sul cibo vi
dico pochissimo vi dico solo che
ci sono state delle presenze costanti
Nelle mense antiche dei Veronesi dai
cereali che ovviamente Servivano anche
per fare Pani minestre polene e che
cambiano molto nel corso del tempo a
seconda anche delle caratteristiche
climatiche per cui c'è un passaggio da
Cervi cereali come il miglio e il panico
che amavano i climi secchi a cereali
come il frumento il grano che amano orzo
che amano invece i climi più umidi Poi
molti leguminose molta frutta pensate
che i romani in età romana doveva
esistere qui nel veronese un un frutto
che viene chiamato una malalata di una
specie di Ma noi pensiamo una mela
cotogna con la buccia un po' la NASA Ma
se poi c'è qualche botanico in aula che
vuole darci qualche idea di proposito
magari e poi le carni in particolare di
bambini perché dobbiamo immaginarci un
paesaggio molto diverso con tante Querce
tante ghiande il pesci che dall'età
Romana hanno una grandissima diffusione
molte volte sono citate le anguille del
Garda o questa salsa che si chiamava
garum che gli antichi facevano facendo
essiccare le interiora dei pesci
mescolandole con spezie devo dire che
probabilmente neanche il più così
entusiasta degli archeologi avrebbe
voglia di assaggiarla perché doveva
essere davvero un po' disgustosa Ma
appunto i romani piaceva molto che
arrivava qui da paesi lontani come la
Spagna attraverso il trasporto tipico
che era quello delle anfore e con le
anfore arrivava anche l'olio che
nonostante lui ci aspettassimo di
trovare in quantità Maggiore non
crediamo che fosse una delle grandi
produzioni di età romana perché la sua
produzione inizia più tardi inizia nel
Medioevo prima le analisi chimiche che
abbiamo fatto nelle pentole usate in
cucina dimostrano un grande uso invece
dei grassi animali delle salse Quando
arrivano i romani portano con loro anche
le tradizioni perché anche la cucina è
un mix di saperi di tradizioni di
innovazioni che cambiano appunto a
seconda del cambiare anche del potere
politico voglio parlarvi invece di vino
perché io credo che il vino sia una
specificità un'identità oggi di questa
città che punta molto tutto il suo
motore economico proprio anche su questo
prodotto che l'ha fatta la famosa nel
mondo basti pensare a manifestazioni
come Vinitaly oppure anche a un museo
sul vino che si sta cercando di pensare
e di realizzare e che darebbe una grande
risonanza anche internazionale ancora
una volta questo tema Ebbene fra i circa
200 vini che sono nominati dagli autori
antichi per l'età Romana due sono
proprio vini definiti retici prodotti
come dicono gli autori antichi in agro
veronensium cioè nel territorio dei
Veronesi oppure dicono anche nella terra
del Dotto Catullo che tutti sappiamo era
appunto Verona
E questa il fatto che si chiamavano però
retice non Veronesi ci ha fatto pensare
che fossero prodotti proprio in quel
territorio dove vivevano gli arosnates
una popolazione che gli antichi stessi
definivano di origine eretiche che è la
Valpolicella una zona che continua a
avere una straordinaria tradizione
vinicola anche proprio per la qualità
dei suoi terreni dei suoi climi e qui in
questa terra attraverso gli scavi
abbiamo raccolto proprio tutta una serie
di testimonianze di resti botanici i
Pollini di vite il legno carbonizzato
proprio della vite ma anche dell'Olmo
con cui la vita veniva maritata secondo
una tradizione etrusca che viene
importata qui e tanti vinaccioli che in
base proprio agli studi delle loro forme
abbiamo capito essere della vite
domestica con cui si faceva il vino e
poi qui abbiamo trovato anche tutti i
resti di quegli strumenti di quegli
spazi per la lavorazione ci hanno
permesso di capire anche come
producevano il vino i calca cioè questi
spazi dove veniva calpestato come vedete
In queste immagine per poi mettere il
mosto in queste grandi vasche che erano
i cosiddetti lacci e abbiamo analizzato
queste vasche con le analisi
biomolecolari e abbiamo proprio trovato
le tracce di uva non fermentata e quindi
appunto di Mosto e poi il momento in cui
veniva ulteriormente schiacciato come
dice un bellissimo Passo del Vescovo
Zenone per tirar fuori tutta la dolcezza
fino al midollo di queste vinacce
attraverso i torchi di cui ovviamente
non abbiamo più il legno che si perde
nel tempo ma abbiamo come vedete in
questa immagine i
contrappesi che venivano usati appunto
da questi da questi strumenti e poi
tutta la fase della fermentazione che
non avveniva come nell'Italia
centro-meridionali in questi grandi otri
che forse avete già visto più volte
negli scavi ma siamo certi e venisse
attraverso le botti botti che altri
autori antichi ci dicono iperbolicamente
grandi come case e che Anche questa è
una tradizione celtica locale diversa
probabilmente una scelta per le
caratteristiche ambientali di questa
zona Ma anche proprio per quelle
tradizioni di cui abbiamo già parlato e
una fermentazione che in particolare
nella Valpolicella veniva anche tenendo
caldo il mosto in ambienti riscaldati su
pilastrini con l'aria calda perché
allora come oggi evidentemente l'uva
veniva lasciata da appassire e poi
veniva lavorata più tardi Ebbene Questo
vino retico doveva avere un pregio
straordinario pensate Io non lo so se a
me ha stupito tantissimo ma io credo che
neanche voi lo potevate immaginare il
vino retico arrivava addirittura a Roma
sulla tavola dell'imperatore Augusto ce
lo racconta Svetonio che amava
raccontare le curiosità delle vite dei
Cesari e ci dice che lo beveva proprio
con grande gusto a ogni pasto Non solo
ma anche l'abbiamo trovato delle sue
tracce in Germania perché li abbiamo
trovato questo monumento funera di un
mercante di vino il cui nome Ci lega
proprio al territorio della Valpolicella
che come vedete in questa immagine viene
rappresentato tra botti di cui abbiamo
parlato prima e con in mano uno
strumento che sembra un odierno
tast-venn Insomma un vino che doveva
avere una grande risonanza
internazionale ma anche che doveva
essere importato da altre parti perché
evidentemente il fabbisogno era molto
alto perché perché non era usato solo
nelle tavole Nelle mense dei Ricchi Ma
perché veniva usato anche in medicina ce
lo dice un medico che dice che il vino
serviva per i problemi di stomaco e
moltissimo in cucina Come anche oggi noi
lo usiamo No abbiamo visto con le
analisi chimiche sempre nei contenitori
delle pentole molto usato nelle cotture
il vino l'aceto il mosto cotto per
piatti che ancora oggi Restano nella
nostra tradizione sempre con quella
mescolanza appunto di tradizioni e di
gusti che cambiano nel tempo e questo ce
lo conferma sono anche le ricette di
appicciole poche ricette che arrivano
dall'età Romana di questo cuoco che era
molto amante della tavola e del buon
cibo
Ebbene Abbiamo anche trovato che anche
nelle classi medio basse si usava il
vino addirittura come offerta per i
defunti analizzando le tombe che abbiamo
trovato nel veronese abbiamo visto molte
volte nei contenitori lasciate
all'interno delle tombe tracce proprio
di vino bianco e rosso l'abbiamo trovato
anche nei tubuli con cui si tornava
sulle tombe a celebrare a ricordare i
propri defunti portando loro e facendo
versando loro ancora una volta appunto
il vino Insomma una grande quantità di
questi prodotti e un ultimo Passo
importante che voglio raccontarvi è che
anche nel tardo antico abbiamo un autore
che ci parla del vino Veronese
Cassiodoro nel V secolo ci racconta di
un vino che doveva essere così pregiato
ad arrivare ancora una volta sulla
tavola del storico ed era un vino che
lui descrive fatto proprio con
l'appassimento delle delle grappoli
d'uva poi lasciato nel questi vasi di
legno che sono appunto Le Botti Quindi
con tecniche che ancora una volta
richiamano le odierne tecniche usate
nella Valpolicella e anche ce lo
descrive ci dice che era un vino rosso
come La porpora pastoso dolce dice quasi
una bevanda da mangiare e ancora una
volta ci sembra quasi di bere leggendo
questo passo un vino della Valpolicella
Quindi sarà molto interessante cercare
oggi la di vedere quelli che sono
appunto il dna dei vinaccioli che
abbiamo trovato con lo scavo e cercare
di capire Quindi i vitigni antichi e
questo è un passo importante che da un
valore aggiunto al nostro progetto
perché ci potrà permettere di dare un
vero contributo anche a quelle
narrazioni una parola che oggi va molto
di moda che possono essere specializzate
anche delle Industrie vinicole Veronesi
andando alla ricerca dei loro dei primi
passi proprio delle radici storiche
della vocazione di questo territorio e
quindi che cosa mi porta a casa da
questo progetto e dal vino il concetto
fondamentale che la storia è continuità
ma anche trasformazione Quindi anche
nella microstoria nell'alimentazione
possiamo vedere lo specchio della macro
storia continuità In che senso nel senso
come vi dicevo prima di queste
tradizioni di procedure tecniche che
rimangono inalterate e che sono una
mescolanza di saperi come vi dicevo
prima il saperi locali che si fondano
con I saperi portati dall'esterno per
contribuire insieme in una società
tremendamente inclusiva e fortunatamente
inclusiva come era quella di Roma da cui
abbiamo tanto da imparare ma anche
trasformazione perché il gusti cambiano
e chi ha provato a fare il vino antico
il vino Romano progetti
italiani francesi dicono che il vino è
un vino molto diverso dal nostro il
fatto che veniva trasportato nelle
anfore che erano rivestite di Peci di
resine trasforma quel gusto dava Sapori
e profumi che oggi non Non
siamo abituati insomma a sentire a
gustare Però io credo che sarebbe
comunque interessante provare a produrre
quel vino perché sarebbe un modo per far
partecipare anche le papille gustative
alla conoscenza per dare un senso anche
di emozione sensoriale appunto a questo
senso di storia che io credo proprio la
quello che ci deve veramente interessare
incuriosire capire il nostro passato per
capire meglio il nostro presente e
allora in attesa che speriamo si faccia
Questo vino antico Godiamoci un buon
bicchiere del vino Veronese virtualmente
ma anche io spero tra poco realmente
dicendo a tutti voi un Prosit che ancora
una volta è un augurio che viene
dall'antico Grazie
[Applauso]